[Music]
[Applause]
Tim kirchen ESPN Hall of Famer ESPN
baseball analyst kind enough to join us
to talk about the game and how would you
recap the first week of spring training
with these new rules Timmy
well Dan I'm pleasantly surprised
how well things are going now look I'm
not suggesting that everything's great
and we don't have way more adjustments
to go from here and something could go
terribly wrong but I did a game the
other day from the booth Dan it was we
had 21 strikeouts 17 walks and the game
lasted three hours and five minutes
that game last year last four hours and
15 minutes I also did a game that was 12
to 7 19 runs scored and the game was
played in two hours and 59 minutes again
last year that game takes four hours
this is the point the players
surprisingly have adjusted very quickly
to this in part because they don't have
much of a choice and the Yankees Dan
played a game the other day in Orlando
without a pitch clock because they
didn't have the technology there and
they still played the game in two hours
and 30 minutes because the players were
already in the mindset that we got to go
here listen we're not in a rush but we
got to move there's no dead time so so
far I'm really surprised with the
biggest rule change the pitch clock has
gone better than I expected any downside
well sure I mean we've we had a game
decided Well not a guy not being in the
Box we've had a catcher knot in the box
and we've had pictures go late so yes
Dan that game that happened between the
Red Sox and the Braves which ended on a
violation that simply can't happen
during the regular season if it happens
during the postseason we're dead if it
happens in the World Series the game
will fold up immediately so this this is
why we're playing 30 spring training
games this is why everyone has six weeks
to figure this out and again I'm not
suggesting there won't be minor tweaks
but I've spoken to Major League Baseball
and they basically have told me these
are the rules these are the rules we're
going to have on opening day I just hope
we get there in one piece and so far I
think so good I know that when you have
the Yankees game Aaron Rodgers or uh
Aaron Rodger uh uh who's our home run
King uh Aaron judge Aaron judge
completely different from Aaron Rodgers
but Aaron judge is miked up and he said
you know I don't think about the
previous pitch now when I'm in the Box
you don't have time to step out and like
oh man I missed my pitch or uh I look
bad on that pitcher he fooled me with
that now it's I get right back in the
batter's box but I still feel like it's
more of a pitcher's advantage to him
because they can decide I'm going to
speed this up as you know much as I want
or as quick as I want you got to get in
there I have a little bit more you know
leeway with my my pitch clock than you
do getting into the batter's box yes
another surprise for me this spring Dan
the first day Buck show Alder said watch
the hitters are gonna have more trouble
adjusting than the pitchers and that's
precisely what's happened I asked Justin
Verlander what about the new rules his
eyes lit up and he goes I love them I
asked Garrett Cole and he said oh I love
them Max Shares are oh I love the new
rules here's what Max hearser the mad
scientist did the other day some kid
gets in the box with 18 seconds left on
the clock and Max Scherzer gets right
into the stretch and he stares at this
poor kid for 14 seconds now Dan you
played in your day and you know when
that picture stares at you for three
seconds it's uncomfortable as Scherzer
told me eight seconds is in
eternity he went 14 seconds The Hitter
just freezes at that point he's
paralyzed because he's not used to being
in that spot before so I think our
really smart really good veteran
pitchers are going to use some of these
rules to their advantage and I repeat I
think the pitchers have an advantage
here over the hitters and damn we put in
all these new rules to give the hitters
a better chance against this remarkable
pitching that they see every day and now
I think the pitchers are getting another
boost we're talking to Tim kirchen Hall
of Famer ESPN baseball analyst I've got
some over unders here Tim Aaron judge
over under home runs 45 and a half
I'm going over I'm not saying he's going
to hit 65 and top last year but he's in
great physical shape he's a way better
hitter than he was three years ago it's
got a really short stroke which we saw
last year's average went up strikeouts
went down and he's so strong Mark
deshara once told me how strong he is he
goes he stands to uh everyone's hitting
a driver Aaron judge is hitting a
forearm That's How Strong he is and he
doesn't need much so I'm going to say he
hits more than 48 five and a half homers
shohei Otani 35 and a half homers
I'm going to go over there too that that
guy is so unbelievably strong and even
though he pitches every fifth day he
plays every day and I'm going over on
35.
over under 500 million dollars for
shoheheotani's next contract
oh he's going over that he's going to
break every record by a mile I think
Juan sotom has a chance to get extended
before
Otani gets his next deal I think soda
will get the biggest contract ever and
then I think ohtani will top that
because again Dan we've never seen
anybody like this but does he get two
salaries Tim
well it doesn't matter how they do it
the two salaries will add up to the
biggest contract ever and there are a
bunch of teams that are really going to
be interested and there are a bunch of
teams that seem to be saving up their
money right now to afford him
can the Angels afford him
uh I think they can and I think they're
actually doing the right thing here is
holding on to him in other words not
creating him last off season and they're
going to try to win and they're going to
try to convince him that we're going to
win here and we're going to win long
term here and we're going to build
around you and you're going to be Mike
Trout's teammate for maybe 10 more years
um if that doesn't happen if they get to
the trade deadline and the angels are
not going to the playoffs and they don't
have a bright future I think that's when
they're gonna have to trade ohtani but I
wouldn't trade him until then I would do
everything it takes to try to win this
year and prove to him or or good enough
and we're gonna and you're gonna be the
biggest star in the world playing here
as opposed to maybe somewhere else where
there are other big stars other than
Mike yeah I think that I I would still
I'd have to go do I want to be Mike
Trout
I can be the best player in baseball I'm
not playing in any postseason games why
would he have confidence in the Angels
organization considering what has
happened with Mike Trout
well that's a good point Dan I'm not
suggesting he's gonna play for the
Angels next year I'm just giving you the
scenario that they might be able to keep
him a they have to be able to afford him
no matter what he wants and they just
have to do like the Giants did a couple
years ago and other teams come out of
nowhere and suddenly they're good that
has to happen for the angels to keep
Otani I think that's the only way
otherwise he's going to go to a team
where he can win who wouldn't want to do
that
give us the team or teams that if we
talk to you in July
you can say I told you so maybe some
surprises
you know Dan I I'm not one to avoid the
question but I just don't see these huge
surprises this year I I looked at the
playoff teams in each league and I think
you could be pretty certain this is how
it's going to work look I think the
angels I just said this but I think the
Angels could be better the Angels were a
bad team last year but with a healthy
trout ohtani at his best they did some
really nice things their starting
pitching is better than people think I
think they're one team that could go
from not very good at all to the
playoffs the Rangers also we talk a lot
about the Rangers so they don't qualify
as a surprise team but they have a
chance to get to say 82 wins this year
which is a big jump for them but that's
as far as I'm going I just don't see a
sub 500 team you know winning the World
Series this year I just don't see it I
also want to know
baseball's I know what their philosophy
is now with the runner at second and
Extra Innings but I wonder what the new
rule changes Tim
are we going to need to put a runner at
second base to speed up the game when
we're speeding up the game why do I need
to put a runner at second base to start
the 10th inning
well I'm completely with you on this Dan
I'm sorry I'm 66 years old we put we
played this game awfully well for well
over a hundred years and I still do not
understand why we have to put that guy
at second to start the Tenth Inning of a
tie game I just don't get it and I never
will and yet there are people in the
game lots of people in the game who love
it but Dan you're right these speed up
rules are working we're trying to keep
the players healthier I think it's okay
to ask uh for quicker games and
healthier players that maybe we can play
until someone actually wins the game and
I know people hate to hear this some of
the greatest games I've ever covered in
my life are 15 Innings 18 Innings I've
covered 20 inning games yes we have to
work a lot harder yes you're late for
dinner all of that stuff but it makes
for really good baseball sometimes and I
wish they would outlaw that and they're
not we had Dave Roberts on the Dodger
manager and I said what do you think of
the new rules he goes gives me more time
to drink wine
you know all all kidding aside Dan Aaron
Boone went to his team and said 30 fewer
minutes that means we're on the bus in
30 fewer minutes on the plane you're
home 30 minutes earlier and most
important as we try to keep these these
players healthy he said it's 30 minutes
Less on your feet during the day nothing
is more tiring than standing in right
field in a game the last four hours and
20 minutes it is a tiring experience and
we can keep our players healthier which
we're trying to do with shorter games
always great to talk to you Tim thank
you
see you Dan take care Tim kirchen ESPN